I say this not to degrade a woman but to
understand y'all women do not understand
how men think
they do not respect you and you are
doing this and you think you're earning
something and and you're a bad B because
you would make all this money you're
going to die on that hill with all your
money by yourself look at what Cher got
to do right now and I'm not putting
share down because she you know saying
she did her thing but she's having she
stole it's actually more shares value
she stole Amber Rose's man
she is in her 70s and she sold a woman
in her 30s man and and do you know the
embarrass and she got a forehead tattoo
for that man and share a woman 40
something years older than her snatched
her man go share girl bye like like if
Amber if it's that much why is Brittany
Renner not wife though why is Amber Rose
not wiped up look at if the old
Hollywood stars who are not wiped up
they're beautiful women
they in the media running their mouth
yeah not only that but they hoes look at
Christina Millions
right like there's women
right where are the wives and media
that's not what's highlighted what's
highlighted it's the Britney reiners are
the people who are selling this
lifestyle in these gen Z babies are
eating it up they think that that's what
men want yeah
but that's why because we aren't being
talked sorry we have no Representatives
did any of you ever as a kid did wait
did any of you ever as a kid want to
grow up wait wait did any of you ever as
a kid grow up and want to be a housewife
no yes really you did yes like
even till now I'd want to do like house
that'd be a housewife but like maybe
work like two days from home
I was gonna say yes and then she had a
lot of extra yes there's Housewives she
didn't say Housewives but how many were
raised you weren't why were you raised
to be a housewife like I grew up in
southern baptist and submission like a
lot of women think it's dirty I'm like
this is standard model that's like
asking for doors and windows on a car do
you do you feel like you're a race to be
a housewife
um
not like with my dad and things like
that as in I saw that growing up but I
my mum like took me out to cook to clean
and things like that so that's what I'm
comfortable doing and then as you get
older and you realize you do have to
work and you're used to it you think I
would want to bring something to the
table as well like working and
intelligence and things like that but
also still want to but you're a
Housewives for the CEO of your
corporation in the company a lot of
women say I don't want to be a domestic
slave I want to have my own money that
CEO that's your daddy that's your sugar
daddy that's who you shaking it for yes
sir yes man he's paying everything for
you and you think that's Freedom when
this man don't like they if they have if
they have to make Cuts in the company
you're out they don't care about you
that there's nothing about you you're
not valuable and you have to compete in
it is tiresome and you're exhausted your
kids suffer your kids are are Buck Wild
like like I don't think people see the
consequences but I don't blame young
women I think it's a failure of older
women
who we have indoctrinated our younger
younger women you know Maggie and I like
I'm I'm 41 and Maggie is an older woman
and me
I know I blame older women
yeah we did we didn't said like we I
mean I personally did my mother did in
the women in my family have but I know
in large we have failed these younger
women and we've let them just run the
streets and we have not checked our
daughters I I let me catch my daughter
my mother today if I post a picture at
my age my mother is 74. I am 41. let me
post a picture where the dress is a
little too much short
my mother would text me and say you look
and I feel shame and embarrassment and I
feel like I failed my family I think
it's a failure of the family structure
my father he doesn't have to say
anything him and I won't talk for days
he's my best friend and I said that like
he's just like Mel like like your mother
told you what like you like and I think
a lot of women have not had the the love
of a family of of men
to to tell them the truth and and that's
why they hated Kevin Samuels because he
was a fatherly figure that told them the
truth and they didn't want to hear it
like your average your average hoe like
and you have whole activity and if you
want to get better you have to do better
but the the Rebellion no one's ever been
in your life to discipline you so it's
like who are you to tell me what to do
because you're you you never had to
discipline you can't even believe
someone would tell you the truth about
you but there was a love for you and he
wanted you to grow but that's even
that's why they celebrated his death
because now we're free to be hoeing and
nobody's going to hold us accountable
she was looking at me and calling me
Maggie
because I knew she met me but she's like
Maggie I'm Auntie Jenny and the other
thing is um when it comes to the old
people about raised to be a I was raised
to be a wife my mom I also my mom get up
early in the morning and do stuff and
cook stuff and even when my mom got
divorced with my dad I still kept it up
I started to go and you know visit my
dad as you make sure dad got his food I
remember washing his clothes by hand you
know and I I thought you know what I
want to do that I want to be a housewife
because in in my day you had to wash
things by hand now you've got washing
machines
people are making it sounds like it's so
hard
being a housewife's a piece of piece
that's it you you work out your routine
and I've seen women do it where they can
I've improved it to probably not rush
around and make yourself do nothing all
day and you can rush around with all mod
cons you can get that house Tip Top get
everything sorted two hours before you
get some dinner cooked house clean
because you've got all the mod cons so
women are saying oh yeah I want to be a
housewife but I want I also want a job I
don't want that job you've got a job the
job is to look after your man your
children the house what more do you want
you've got the car you can go where you
like you can fool them out because what
all he cares is like you know get his
balls emptied and getting his belly full
how many people take a picture of their
house right now if I told you right now
take a picture of your house every room
in your house I want to see how it's
organized decorated and I want to see it
is it a hot ass mess is it about is it
does it look like a trap house is it
like a crash site is your mattress on
the floor is your it you're worried
about bag but your home you where you
dwell you're in the street if you lit
you live in the streets if you're about
that life you're not taking care of a
home you don't really care what's going
on in there we've seen these videos on
YouTube and you have to say to yourself
like I'm not making a home like what man
wants to come home
my you know in my home smells ratchet a
lot of women your pH balance
like like and I'm just going to say this
because we're going to be out here we
out here right like we're talking about
sex work
like how many men right now you take
your panties off and they can smell them
uh oh
could you not take a shower for a couple
days and your panties still smell but
then that's just not still why are you
not gonna that's like yeah
is banging why because yeah vaginosis
has passed and I'm not putting as a
shame but a lot of young women your
mothers have not taught you how to even
wash yourself properly douche okay no it
ain't even about you shouldn't even do a
douche like and that's what I want to
talk about that because a lot of young
women have not been taught this and
we've got to have these conversations
your your boxes for the street but your
box
take go to the bathroom you take them
off let me as a woman I'll Stand in that
back I go to the bathroom and I smell
you I come in the bathroom after you and
I'm smelling
[Laughter]
a lot of these women your ass stink
stink and you don't even you think this
is cute you don't wear perfume you think
you just spray some body spray you don't
even know how to clean you're not
hygienic let me tell you something I
ain't got to take a shower for a week
if I chose not to I will I will I listen
listen my mother because if she taught
me you come around my mother and she's
74. she has no body odor from head to
toe she has no body hair
why because she was taught how to be a
woman right now it's about being sexual
but not how to be a actual woman and
have your womb clean your womb has been
ran through it's been it's it's Plan B
it's Planned Parenthood it's been ran
through so many it's so many sticks
inside those walls and I want to say
this in a way not to criticize you but
to understand
you have been degraded by the street the
the street has once your mind gone they
want you ran through with vaginosis they
want you going to the clinic they want
you taking the medication they want you
on Plan B why because the because your
mothers have failed you your fathers
have failed you the society has failed
you but there are women like me
like Pearl oxygen no I was gonna say it
and Maggie The Substitute Teacher where
we say we love you we don't we know
you've been failed and it's not a
judgment on you we want you to win and
we're trying to give you the cheat code
so you don't have to be out here like
these other women and struggle
take this mess off you don't need all
this on you like like like you got your
nails done your wig fixed you got all
this done I go to the bathroom after
your ass stank girl that BV is
BVT
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible